[Applauso]
oggi nuova challenge tre colori di acqua
colorata challenge grazie mille perché
se l'avete consigliata voi io gli ho
chiesto cosa volete che faccia da
challenger tre colori di colla e ci
avete consigliato un sacco di cose e
questa proposta nell'acqua colorata mi
piace un sacco perché io adoro i blitz
live ei silenzi grisly molti contenitori
non c'è solo acqua colorata in alcuni
c'è anche colorante all'olio lunghe sono
i più fortunati perché così cui si dà un
bel colore vivo e acceso e in alcuni si
sono i diritti
migliaia le sorti della stessa perché le
premesse per circolati questa sale anzi
come le nostre challenge tre colori di
colla abbiamo fatto tre colori di
glitter tre colori di pigmenti tre
colori di tinte ad olio andremo con la
band a pescare un colore ogni volta una
volta pestato dobbiamo raggiungerlo
nostro slime abbiamo già un po di colla
po abbiamo preso i vecchi perché se non
puoi non ci sta più niente dentro perché
uscirà il 3 o uscire aggiunta di zilli
sicuramente quindi un jeans lime gigante
non vedo l'ora di vederle ai colori che
mischieremo vedremo di che colore
diventerà vitale ovviamente non vuole
che diventi grigio marrone che odia io
non voglio che diventi verde quindi
sapere di non pescare questi due alcuni
tra l'altro sono colori un pò mischiate
esempio marina un mix di colori c'è
anche il mero quindi solo le reti siamo
fortunati italia suggerito una pausa
fase meteo che il secondo turno invece
di se li erano inventati che sceglierà
siri qui il secondo turno se gli arazzi
per noi glieli le regole sono
semplicissime scrivetelo nei commenti
secondo poi alla fine di colori filoni
nostri zai barra anziché colore si
rendono e di critica
io oggi sono team viola anche se non ho
niente signor andrea di blocco invece
allora io potrete votare mettere il
sondaggio fa e potrebbe votare quali
flati dei pesci che sia per l'aspetto
che per sony che se volete vedere al
rizzoli lifecasting assicurino i
commenti che il personale non ci volete
vedere
prendete i pop corn
[Applauso]
[Musica]
c'è in progetto benda si aspetta che
devo può cambiare il nome di tutti i
colori
insomma non cambia tra l'altro dobbiamo
su per non farli cadere un super attenti
perché così questo non può in bilico
steccare qualcosa si macchiano
completamente io oppure la felpa bianca
disastro ma viene preferita si morda i
top rider e rubare ok ho fatto stai
attento devi solo indicare non devi
toccare dc dove sono
allora questa è la linea
mamma mia rimani così in alto
così non ci sono rischi qua e se il
lesso aspetta basta poco poco basta ok
hai preso il blu per ora per me se poi
ti capita mai sapere
stabilizzato dopo che perde anche se lo
devono bere tutto volevo mettere tutto
volevo dire tutto ora sarà un meta fare
una meta unicorno a in tanti mi avete
detto bellissima donna in panda in
realtà era propagato e un grasso solo
che non so perché dire che sono stato
così tonde o prima erano più appunto
comunque gli hanno fatto le orecchie
tonde quindi sembra nuova sala un po
punto l'uomo quanto non lontanto pausa
proprio un pub a ok allora sono pronta
mischiano attento è l'attenzione
stai attento che io ho paura che tu
faccia vedere solo dove si è associato è
affetto da allora sei in vantaggio ce
l'ho fatta
aspetta dove l'asfalto non c'è allora
dimmi allora di vedere qui si è aperto
questa la lingua in alto tra loro più
basso ok ok allora se no certo questo
abbassa ua ok questo sì viviamo
e certo questo non vedersi bellissimo
questo colore un fiore più bello ancora
salute ora possiamo iniziare a mente che
tocca in italia per tre motivi
barrios superficie l'altro con tutti i
glitter vorrebbe molta acqua separato
dalla colla rotta posso giurarlo certo
dei mischiarlo vediamo un po che diventa
sarà su perso questo personaggi che cosa
fantastica figli va bene non lascio così
stato mi piace de nicolò e poi noi
allora mette il mio bellissimo viola vai
ma non i glitter smentì però che bello
l'estrema di rimane separata così sembra
un a valence estrae modesto
ora vado a mischiarlo che bello spero
che rimanga viola anche se non penso
brutto tiro perché mi capiti qualche
colore decente dopo bellissimo lille ai
tiratori ma alcun obiettivo ragione te
che stai torneranno insegnerà dice la
falsa notizia stessa ora non si perda
dire certo qualcosa stretto speriamo
bene
non ho capito bene secolo iniziale
ospitiamo carta parte di sandro berti
limitato il numero dei non so se ho
capito bene merda
non so se ho capito bene il grillo che
sarebbe detto che sei stata cattiva non
so se ho capito bene sono sempre qui a
tua disposizione
[Musica]
il verde è sfumato eh sì che formerà
molto bene la realtà con il viola
io ricevo numero tra 26 dimmi un numero
tra 2 e 6 il numero di pagine ok
cosa ho trovato tanti nuova loro che
ascoltare sei un numero tra 1 e 5
il giallo si rendono mi piace recenti
sempre siri non mi piace che scelti
sempre uno come uscirà anche un blu e
giallo quindi stiamo abbiamo pure se
entrambi la maledizione del verde adesso
da aspettare sino a verde perché riesce
il giallo a me non lo so cosa uscirà
viola mischiato con il burden lo
scopriremo
adesso qualcuno quasi dimenticata da
registrare la clip si sono molto
contenta di tutto ciò è tale se
dimenticate di registrare cammino in
crisi mia vita a vedere che cosa è
rimasto troppo alla farina stalla
cacchetta del colorante ad olio non
vanno a caccia
per fortuna non si stacca così almeno
l'altra dall'altro lo slime però pitasi
dimenticate registrare quindi non avete
pensato che lei il mescolamento è così
che bello il meno grigio il ritrovato
all'interno grigio e ci sono anche di
glitter verdi almeno sia verdi che viola
ma il colore the imbruttito un po mi
aiuterà impediamo che verrà allora
eccola giallo bluetooth come diventare
perdere cosa per don ridare male ai
ripari e sposta i verde blu o non sta
diventando
ne ho finora di belen tu perché tu e
verde acqua e le tigri e un mare
bellissimo e un celeste acqua questo non
perde acqua non si perde acqua e gli
appelli in arrivo è bellissimo quindi
anche piazza mi piace tantissimo che
colore vorresti ti capitasse adesso a
questi del ed il verde cioè che cosa
diventa un'arte acceso per deriva dalla
limonta io vorrei che mi capitasse o
questo rosa o l'arancione l'arancione a
colori diventerebbe con l'arancione il
terzo e ultimo round decideremo i sacri
di carta forno carta forno gettando dai
20 ai 100 tesi con ok
non è mai bello tutto come sia quello
che volevo non riesco a capire come sia
quello che volevi maestro molto molto
battuta perché almeno non lo perché noi
[Applauso]
siamo un po di galassie un pochettino
più di colore a questo ma la mano chi
non capisce niente di tanto quando far
la vita con la coca cola rotola sul
campo l'arancio respiriamo
per il resto capito
arpav di v dove sta sono qui ok e perde
la decisione definitiva dello stare
attenta allora ero troppo contento
perché ci sono dei glitter e dei
pigmenti di vedere o non dovrei più
bello anch'io che il mini lo stalker a
diventare un colore stupendi stima cosa
spettacolare glitter e i pigmenti guarda
ti cade tutto il basso sembrano quelle
lampade si chiamano nelle nottate con i
twitter la polonia lampo del plasma
rilasciate da guardare orari manduca a
guardarlo rilassante a percorre però io
mi dovevi vedere come diventato sly
modesto roma prima vediamo il suo slam
super verdi hanno prima vediamo cosa ci
siamo persi siamo persi è molto carino
questo allora sotto c'è come si chiama
la tenuta dopo li portava sotto e poi ci
sono anche dei pigmenti sotto a esita ad
un è rimasta un po incastrata la
bacchetta quindi ci siamo posti questo
bellissimo arancione rosa per un po più
scuro un po rosso e sopra aveva i leader
rossi rossi ma niente questa sera stiamo
bene per vennero berlin così diventa più
forte come colore un capo di rose in
nero ora così diventa un verme
scoraggiante
ma no non diventa grido come perché bel
colore verde che uscito adesso ma adesso
non è più non verde acqua adesso un
verde acqua sporca e non vediamo più
verde ma che te l'ho detto io so che è
bello alla fine è mai
ebbene la nostra bottiglia ora di rosa e
twitter
[Applauso]
il bello sta diventando no non è vero e
tutto ciò che è volato motivo che bella
ora in b ci sono cicli teverina tempo
verde acqua e viola odio il mio a
tantissima poi quindi ci vorrà un sacco
di tempo per attivarlo allora finora
fare le veci di più il mio primo
digitale scrivete di commenti che di
curiosi di vedere come di mettere una
volta attivi misura curiosissima e spero
che vi si attiverà perché di acqua ce
n'è tantissima del caso aggiungiamo un
po di colla
quindi speriamo che si attivi a volare
sigli allora in pratica si sono stati
momenti di panico perché stanno provando
ad attivarlo ma essendoci così tanta
acqua non riuscivamo subito ad attivarlo
allora abbiamo pensato ma aggiungiamo un
pochino di colla così forse riusciamo ad
attivarlo
e se volete conto che la collera finita
via quella bianca che quella trasparente
e abbiamo detto oh mio dio cosa facciamo
questo video sarà un super bale perché
non uscirà lo slime invece poi abbiamo
continuato ad aggiungere bicarbonato
soluzione presidente abbiamo aggiunto
più carbonato del solito ma so
nonostante zione del nostro comunque
occorre l'astico non sentito e piano
piano piano piano si è formato ti faceva
malissimo il braccio perché attivarlo è
stato un impresa però ne volta la pena
che figata lei e business plan
a parte che sono super contenta che il
colore alla fine è riuscito bene perché
sotto un
viola lilla non so perché cito gianluca
bocchi comunque il colore la curiosità
bello per fortuna ma anche sensato che
sia partita gp ora li faccia sentire un
po i suoni vista
[Musica]
e bellissimo visibili che ho mai fatto
forse è vero se vi ricordate questo lo
slime tipo acqua e quello era molto più
triste e troppo belle epoque invece
benissimo e mi piace un sacchetto di
fungo gt delusi allora che volto di date
e ora lo strangolamento
guardate il tessuto per me io sono per
grossi tra l'altro sentite chi è vero
che il bellissimo alla roberto ora
immediate
e abbastanza degli utili direi forse
meno tigri del suo sì per commesso un
atto nell'area di essere come sono di
spinta di bicarbonato perché mi è
cascato è anche vero che di il mio è
uscito più bella della mia vita è però
vi piace che è molto blog si vede con
questi con questi glitter blu che si
vedono
spero che quando sono venuto un po offre
pochi detto che questo mio
giochiamo il tuo piace un sacco fa il
mio diario
attendo a non mischiarli se molto
consistenza del tuo di questo è male
leggermente più duro che bello questi
obiettivi è anche il colore non così
tanto
anche se mi sembra meno grossi del mio
io più grossi budino nipotina ragù di
noi
andai alla menta che rimuove tutto così
strano libro c'è la ricetta per parenti
live
fatemi sapere se l'avete fatta allora
fin qua e tu sei verde io non la voglio
per lei perde questa scudella l'ing
vediamo che rimbalza
[Musica]
bellina questo contagio potete votare
servito io ho te ambito non solo vinto
pistole usate e orami da succo quattro
cartellini di purificare per 27 altre
sale i nostri video divertenti i nuovi
video che il caos come la preferite